it was only a matter of time before
Chris Pratt became an a-list movie star
he's now at the center of multiple
franchises he star Lord in guardians of
the galaxy Owen in Jurassic world and
Emmitt in the lego movie but Pratt
slowly built up his career with regular
roles on TV and supporting roles in
big-screen productions before earning
his spot on the top throughout it all
Pratt has proven to be a charming
entertaining and most of all hilarious
guy here are some times that the camera
captured him on movie and TV sets
goofing off screwing up and ad-libbing
the OSI one of Pratt's earliest roles
was playing che on Fox's team soap the
OSI and while the part mostly required
him to act like a burnout he did seem to
have a lot of fun with it until he had
to eat on camera that is in one scene he
was supposed to be giving sage advice to
Seth Cohen while eating a bowl of figs
and it probably would have gone off
without a hitch if Pratt hadn't grabbed
a spoiled piece of fruit what's your
number wearing a fat suit might hinder
some actor's ability to bust a move but
that wasn't the case for Chris Pratt and
what's your number Pratt had to bulk up
a bit but he still managed to bust out
some impressively accurate Michael
Jackson dance moves that were totally
uninhibited by the extra poundage he
should put that on his resume parks and
recreation Pratt didn't come out of
nowhere to become the biggest action
hero working today before he started
saving the world he was best known for
his supporting role in NBC comedy Parks
and Recreation but the Inklings of a
hero were still present in his role as
the dumb but eager manchild Andy Dwyer
in this outtake Pratt rapidly hurtled
over a counter and then ditched a
briefcase his character didn't need to
steal by throwing it back from where he
got it amazingly the case nailed a light
switch and left the actors in the dark
hilarious
that's not something
that promise can fix it sorry about
delivery man even though Chris Pratt was
on the cusp of mega success when he
starred in this 2013 comedy he was still
pretty hungry at least that's all we can
assume from watching this outtake of him
chasing a lot of cash from blowing away
in the wind Jurassic world
Pratt's character Owen can do a lot of
things he can ride a motorcycle
he contained velociraptors and he can
even make the t-rex look like a good guy
but acting out one of Owens talents in
particular gave Chris Pratt some trouble
on the set while his character was
capable of doing crazy things Pratt had
a lot of trouble whistling and the
behind-the-scenes footage of his
repeated failed efforts made for some
great b-roll
guardians of the galaxy flying a
spaceship is fun and it would seem that
even pretending to fly a spaceship is
also a thrill because on the set of
guardians of the galaxy Pratt got a
little carried away behind the controls
of the mighty Milano the filmmakers
probably only really needed a second or
two of star-lord looking excited but
Pratt got downright maniacal with his
unbridled glee
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 the
Guardians returned for some more outer
space adventures and guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 but they weren't alone a
few new characters came along including
an ageless celestial named ego who was
star Lord's father played by Kurt
Russell because the movie was set on
several distant planets gravity wasn't
always a given so to replicate that the
actors had to endure a lot of wire work
and in this outtake from the movie Pratt
and Russell had a hard time getting the
hang of things
the film also presented another all-star
blooper when we were introduced to the
High Priestess of the sovereign's she
tried to chat up the star-lord about
breeding techniques and she got this as
an explanation of how Earthlings do it I
personally control half the DNA by doing
something I call doing Caen passengers
for a large portion of his other space
movie passengers Chris Pratt wandered
around a gigantic ship almost entirely
by himself his only human interaction
was with an Android bartender named
Arthur played by Michael Sheen
Arthur provided drinks and a little bit
of companionship and since there wasn't
much else to do
Pratt's character was a patron of the
pub quite often in this outtake Pratt
got a chance to do some drunk acting and
he comically overreacted to arthur's
boozy blue concoction it's amazing none
of these moments made it into the movies
really thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we don't you'll love to
[Music]